[Music]
laughing what's all eternity
PowerShell
hi Eddie so high-level feed the father
okay guys hope you guys are doing well I
just came to the park it's quite
freezing actually and I can see you
shivering that's why we we stood next to
the Sun to get some heat I met what's
your name a thirty-minute Lochan third
Lochan Danny third that dark third
Lochan that rule change that law general
Chiang
I'm Aly call me yeah so basically I'm a
property I just came out this into a
discussion and it was nice to come
across him because there was certain
well there's a view that we both share
and that's basically speaking out
against hey maybe he saw my video will
bring him first I don't know if you've
seen it or with that jada jada yeah yeah
yeah she's so cool britain first year
she tried to harassment I shake my hand
shake my hand bastard yeah yeah I know
no I don't need to I don't ask you to
hold my fire hold my fire you know but
anyways the thing here is is that as you
know hate has been preached by both
extremist Muslims and be extremist
far-right groups and they might find
their very own extremist seats whoever
they may be
yeah one of them who comes to this park
yeah for example so from your point of
view as a Sikh where does it where does
it stand with you and your religion and
the gurus about preaching hate or
joining individuals via extremist
Muslims or non-muslims when it comes to
preaching hate so I'm gonna tell you for
that as the first guru good know what
the FK yeah yeah he's the foundations
the bedrock of seek he ain't here sick
stems from him and he's our in light
enough okay he's our guru I'm
spiritually Lloyd tuna and he told us
clearly in what we have something called
the moon month area which is a root
mantra
what does that mean root man tries
something that we is opening verse and
it is something where we should live
boys rule so we should live by it okay
did you see like the commandments says
it says the truth existed before time
exists now when time story and the truth
will always be around here also says
clearly and ain't no fear no hate yeah
we need to live by this rule no pain I
hate here so if you hate yeah
outside of the fold of of what our faith
teaches us our pathway okay and see how
can you hate the two don't go together
yeah no yeah it's like ya know the to go
hand-in-hand same same same way but hey
if I hate you yeah see kidding because
it's a no fear no hey exact I got for
you yeah I can't hate you yeah same
season is a sin yes same same with us
because I think is it's like I
understand your concern cuz you as here
maybe Kim see Raj which you believe
who's maybe representing you as a seat
and I feel the same way as you when I
see Muslims who are represented might
have hijacked my religion and are going
out in Italy bluntly one feel about Raja
bluntly and as clear as day Raj it's not
a Sikh people like here make my blood
boil yeah like I shouldn't get angry I
shouldn't hate I'm a human I thought
he's make him Sikhs look like he's
embarrassing I was doing our base be
inferred up is called base he's
embarrassing us and I'm standing for
that only what's major upset about him
like what was he openly Muslims I came
here today to meet him and to set him
straight
that was today's mission he was raised
in America but maybe in America you can
watch this maybe you know hopefully he
can fix his ways and understand that
look hates not gonna get us nowhere
be it extremists from all rods are
waiting for you I'm waiting for you be
prepared that Hortons waiting for you so
I won't take no prisoners when it comes
to you you're gonna advise him you okay
he's a bit upset but I I understand make
you I'm not gonna sugarcoat it for him
yeah making in a sweet way yeah yeah I'm
gonna do no sweet what's room yeah I'm
gonna give it to him bro yeah yeah raw I
know you know you know I understand with
your frustration because the same way
like a secured that's how I feel when I
see somebody hijacked in my religion
going and killing innocent people and
then you know what happens you know you
know we
hey we have a these individuals who go
and do this we call them that for
example how are you how are you what the
Prophet said these guys cause more harm
to us than anyone else you know why
because they look like us and they speak
like us and then they do stand maybe
stuff in our name and what happens when
I walk around looking like him he was
like okay he's the same and that's the
way you feel when Raja my comment yeah I
don't send people now to start thinking
because of his hateful hateful things he
says and the way he goes on to
everything is like that same scene the
best one is my duty he's a fartist yeah
yeah well part yeah but it's my duty I
can't stand by and watch injustice yeah
why we can't stand by and watch
injustice I have to openly attack
injustice yes yes yes that's what we're
talking what jeez yes I will just matter
of timing yeah that's what that's what
we're talking about in the plan is
you're standing against oppression yeah
innocent people and that's the reason
why well if you do this video because we
have that common ground and this cos
same with the British problem because if
you see these extremists we Isis or will
appreciate what you do and you're
preaching hey and who is suffering
innocent people look at for example in
the attacks I've been having around by
Muslim deities bad news in there and
then you've got people coming to
Finsbury Park running all the Muslims do
suffering
we're suffering the British non-muslims
and Muslims or six even since you guys
are getting at a because you look like
you're Muslim yeah you said you had an
instance where somebody came to you
telling me terrorize the water and I was
driving in turn it happens but why did
you not say you know i'm normally why
did you not say that you could've easily
you know I'm gone Muslim and move away
to be on this year I tell you I didn't I
don't care if people are gonna hate me
because that hates gonna hurt them it's
not gonna hurt me yeah you can hate me
as much as you want because it's not
gonna it's not gonna have a fact on me
he's gonna make he hates gonna make his
blood boil is gonna make her he's gonna
get the high blood pressure and all that
when you hate and you hate is so
passionate yeah exactly that's not
healthy is unhealthy
so I'd rather have a banana 19 yeah yeah
be healthy
yeah banana don't hate
oh hey have a banana is good please say
yes to potassium yeah exactly and I just
like to hate ya Zi fan typical TV Thank
You a marshmallow
I just wanna [ __ ] I just want to say
loudly yeah yeah thank you too much yeah
thank you yeah Allah Allah says in the
Quran which we creative you nations and
tribes so that you might get to know
each other not that you might you know
fight and despair against each other so
that's why I promise it is really
important as you can see as I see he's
frustrated because why he believes
somebody like someone that we know Raj
you know has been misrepresented him and
he's upset is annoyed how do you think
as Muslims we feel when we have people
extremist going in our name and killing
innocent people this is the reason why
we should stand up to hey no matter
where it comes from Britain first Tommy
Robinson Isis no matter who is from we
as the British public should stand up
against it and talk against it because
Allah says in the Quran speak the truth
even if it's against your own self and
your kinsmen that's a way for me I'm
gonna have my banana and look into the
Sun